I actually did a beginner's class not
that long ago maybe 10-15 minutes ago
and one of the things I had mentioned in
that class and what I tried to encourage
the beginners was to look for games that
inspire them okay
and even as a chess grandmaster today
and been there done that seen it all I
still run across games that inspire me
and I would like to share one of my
discoveries with you one of my favorite
bloggers chess bloggers is a fellow from
Canada his name is Grandmaster Kevin's
bracket so Kevin's bragging on chess
blog and he lives in Portugal and he
plays in the Portuguese chess league as
well as the Spanish chesley gun on his
blog he presented this game that was
played between two new gentleman I'm
going to get their names wrong
grandmaster lee bouzouki it was white
and grandmaster Edward remained from
France was black and like I say you know
this is just a fun inspiring game and I
wanted to share it with our class as he
thinks so efore c5 a Sicilian and open
Sicilian happen and please feel free to
ask any questions this of course in the
Sicilian this tons and tons of
variations this of course a seven a six
is known as the knight or defense made
popular by its namesake miguel knight or
a six and there's lots and lots of moves
for white here white has played Bishop
g5 is one of the main moves
bobby's Fisher favorite
was Bishop c4 what I call the Fischer
variation other people have played g3
h3r up g1 with the idea of g4 in and of
course f4 f4 is also very important move
so lots and lots of choices white played
Bishop e3 what is known as the English
attack so Bishop e3 ePHI and again all
of these moves are I'm not going to say
standard but theoretically well-known
there in books and and lots of players
have played like this now here white
makes a kind of a tricky little move he
plays this little move h3 so why it's
idea is that he wants to first of all
stop the move Knight g4 but also get
ready to expand on the kingside white
reasons that if he could play g4 g5 kick
this night away then this night could
land on the attractive square d5 alright
h3 is not the most popular move in that
position 97 g4 and we see the game
unfolding as follows now with this move
rook c8 one of the things that in
sicilians that's very very common is for
black to sacrifice an exchange for this
knight on c3 doubling White's pawns and
then if blacks Knight could clip this
pawn then for a very very minimal
material loss black usually gets an
excellent game so that's a standard
Sicilian sacrifice what Alexander you're
molinsky might say every Russian
schoolboy knows Queen d2 stopping the
sacrifice h6 to slow down White's
desired advance castles b5
F for and now the game is already
getting a little bit wild Bishop d7
black if he wanted to could have tried B
for a new variation 95 nine takes e4
that may have felt that even though he
won that with us say Black has won upon
black might not be so happy his king is
still stuck in the center and after for
example a move like Queen G to attacking
the knight White has ideas like Bishop
takes a six winning back his pawn ideas
like f4 f5 trying to force the trade of
that bishop on e6 and and in essence
black felt the move before was too
dangerous also I should point out pardon
me that also after B 494 white could
also if he wants play Queen takes before
attacking this knight on d4 which is why
black played bishop
yes King b1 pawn takes Bishop takes 95
and the game is still unfolding nothing
inspiring yet Queen g2 97-95 takes so
far seeing things seem okay for black
and he reasons that he has a really
great night sitting there in the middle
of the board on e5 but if we stop and
think about the position for a second
that's really basically the only thing
that's really great about blacks
position and it is very good white on
the other hand has a lot of
ideas one is if we if we could put a
knight on c6 this would be a very very
good square and that is what white in
fact does he plays 94 with a
dual-purpose idea of both 96 as well as
Knight f5 so although I'm not a hundred
percent sure what black has done wrong
already
I much prefer White's position g6 to
defend the square I just mentioned f5 my
place h4 rook c5 Bishop g2 queen of 6g
fine takes takes rook takes h1 rotates
page one Queen g7 rook h4 king d8 Queen
h3 and here's where the funds begins in
fact black has been severely outplayed
and it's very clear that widest in fact
threatening to play rook invasion to h7
trapping the black queen and winning on
the spot so that's like threat number
one another idea for white obviously as
I mentioned a moment ago is to bring his
knight to c6 that would be Czech and
black has been outplayed
so black feels that the best defense is
a strong offense and he plays the move
Knight to c4 making preparing to meet
the rook invasion rook h7 with Queen
takes d4 white through Sisu that clever
little trick and plays Queen c3
threatening I discovered check against
Blacks king
winning black's queen any questions thus
far it's all very straightforward okay
good night e5 white plays knight c6
check reasoning that black cannot
capture with the night because that will
cost him his queen so the night is now
in a pen he doesn't want to capture with
his rook because that would simply cost
him in exchange and probably the game
black played King c7o as White's looking
at the position he's saying hey man look
at your rook on c5 isn't it trapped boom
b4 game over here to Scott signed the
score sheet white is winning Mike says
well before I resign I'd first like to
play this move whoa where did that move
come from holy cow wait a minute
if white now takes the Queen he's
checkmated
he has checkmated check King Jack King
Jack King and this rook that was trapped
says let me get in the last laugh let me
just get in that last little laughter oh
boy so can you imagine White's absolute
shock when this move Knight d3 was
played but white regain is calm and he
says okay I've got to keep this square
a3 under protection of my queen it's
clear
I can't capture my blacks Queen and if
whites Queen moves any one I also have
to keep in mind Knight d2 check so white
played a fantastic move by default just
retreating the Queen and says hey you
know deep breath you're your rook is
still trapped I'm winning everything's
okay black said well wait a minute wait
a minute how about Queen e5 Queen B five
holy cow
now what's going on let's see what
happened aren't I just a rook up b4 oh
gosh let me go into a huddle again okay
I can't take this night because of
checkmate I can't take this night
because if Czech made it once again I
can't keep the Queen the e1 square
protected with my queen
White has to come up with a great idea
as well white sees that he could move
his night with Czech pawn takes Queen
takes but then black has a perpetual
check with his two knights
do you see the perpetual check so
White's trying to win the game and white
played 96 Czech and unfortunately the
game ended as a draw anyway very
inspiring right but one of the one of
the one of the discoveries that was made
after words was that white could have
won white could have won
in this position how on earth could
white have won the game
the crazy part was that that white had a
miracle win an absolutely miracle win C
takes D six King B seven push the phone
it loves to say so night a three check
is actually blacks best move we'll come
to this in just a second we'll go back
don't worry white takes takes and this
is an incredible situation where just
thanks to one single check the bishop on
g2 wins the game
thanks to this move check that's so wild
because blacks King has no square that
it can move if blacks King moves to b6
we promote with check if blacks King
moves to a7 we play knight c6 check
capture the Queen and make a queen
ourselves so lets us go back a sit so
now we kind of understand what the heck
is going on
King b7 d7 so if you take pardon me if
you take the queen right away
d6 check just a check along this whole
diagonal you've got two nights a queen
and you're absolutely nailed the white
bishop is a monster the problem from
blacks point of view is black wants to
move his King in such a way so that
after his Queen gets taken you'll have a
perpetual check on me a perpetual check
like this so black wants to play this
move allowing a check now he can't move
to the light squares because then he
walks into a discover check now after
this move black would be very very happy
if white were to capture his queen
because then he's got the perpetual
check that he needs to make a draw but
but instead of capturing the Queen white
goes Queen himself check
is this wild or what I mean isn't this
just like an amazing game yeah
definitely if you go King up the board
you got check if the King comes up the
board we've got a check and then our
next move is to take black's queen or
give checkmate so we go back back back
so now we go checking here push night a
three check this is blacks best chance
now in this position white cannot
capture the night because of a
background check down here and it's
black who wins see that one
whoo so white moves his king check King
check now instead of acquiescing to a
draw now that white pawn on c2 is
missing it gives him the opportunity to
take the knight
now here after check variation King
comes here nothing has changed
white still is intending to make a queen
to make a buy meat discover check
forcing black into unto the b6 square so
that we could promote with check we
could take the bishop if we're black we
can go here oops sorry
that wasn't it not there that wasn't
what we wanted this one override hey and
take the Queen anticipating that we'll
be able to take the bishop in case of
check but at this moment because black
has given up his entire army we can just
queen and win the game so lets us go
back and recap for a second so when we
reach this position after the move Queen
h3 we understood
black had been completely outplayed and
white had the advantage and then this
absolutely
stunning move 93 that's like oh and who
you know because of that checkmate that
I showed with the rook check check check
rook mate in case we take the Queen this
great retort Knight d4 this fantastic
move Queen to e5 and here there was
another mating problem let's see what it
was if we play if we take the knight how
can black win
this is check yeah
check
meet so in this position you can't take
the night that was why he white took the
rook and then this wild move be fought
before ooh and ahh and this is the
moment where white bailed out I look for
inspiring games and I just this was
again and it is played in a Spanish
league nobody I mean this game would
have easily been overlooked in the great
current of modern chess affairs and
again you know a shout out to Kevin
scrag it for coming up with his gem and
sharing it with his leader